martelé le faire et transformer le
produit brut en objets d'art antonin de
creux et coutelier ferronnier il
travaille le métal depuis une dizaine
d'années là je pars sur un couteau brut
de forges donc c'est la soie du couteau
va revenir sur elle-même pour faire une
petite boucle
donc là il faut que je tire toute cette
partie là ça va être sur la bigorne on
appelle ça
coûte au tire-bouchon décapsuleur il
fait de ces outils du quotidien des
pièces uniques un travail n'est avant
tout de sa passion pour les métiers
manuels et qui requiert de nombreuses
qualités pour être créatif faut être
manuel faut pas avoir peur de salir de
se brûler ce genre de chose faut être
patient faute faut être minutieux parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de travail de
précision qui peuvent être effectués
quand il ya des petits mécanismes de
couteau pliant par exemple
c'est du travail vraiment assez
minutieux
devant une quinzaine de visiteurs le
ferronnier d'art expose son savoir faire
l'occasion pour les curieux de poser des
questions sur ce métier parfois méconnus
s affairent rouge orange jusqu'à jaune
jusqu'à blanc et après au dessus de
blanc ça commence à pétiller le métal
commence à fondre pour nous des
commandes mortels on ne peut pas laisser
de détails c'est très important de voir
cette évolution du goût de faire jusqu'à
la cuisson jusqu'à la forme et ça c'est
surprenant c'est intéressant de voir pas
grand chose avec la récupération on peut
refaire des choses très joli cette
démonstration permet aussi de donner du
relief aux collections de l'espace métal
de grossouvre
on a la chance d'avoir une très belle
scénographie qui est ludique et
interactive qui explique un petit peu
tout ce travail de la métallurgie mais
au-delà de ça on a besoin de connaître
les savoir-faire de voir l'homme travail
est un événement amené à se reproduire
l'espace métal prévoit déjà de
rassembler différents artisans d'art
pour les journées du patrimoine